let's bring out the director of photo
Regirock an amazing genius that I've
been fortunate not to get to know the
past few years
mr. Takalua didi also I'm here by the
name of
[Applause]
Tom Hiddleston
Mark Ruffalo
Kate Blanchet
a gentle bloom has arrived
nothing started
also catheters
[Applause]
in rachel has excellent your thor
ragnarok casts congratulations thank you
guys for being here thank you so much
for being here that didn't have anything
South Africa's mister has Mark so Thor
does not have this hammer he does not
have a scarf
what is him he doesn't have hair then he
normally would have no uh no belly up so
this looks like a very different floor
totally and characterizing horse races
what's going on what's going on right
now midlife crisis really well I've
heard you've carried a five times
marbles 167 film or something and he let
me personally I got a bit bored of
myself and thought we're going to try
something different
smoked with Tigers work with Kevin and
all of us agreed if we're going to make
it there before we have to really push
the envelope and an experiment and take
it to another level so that was one of
those film was you know cutting chair
breaking Tama changes clothes change the
world and I think that's what you're
going to see in the excited that is
something incredibly unique and
different not only the whole world with
the Marvel Universe and so because we
for used to being in charge I mean like
he never really seems like he has to
break much of a sweat and in this but
from what we've seen [ __ ] off because I
get to ass-kicking this girl and I'm
Levi Larkin on the state to us
[Applause]
and take out a source areas other than
your regions because what we do in the
shadows is want to be great information
that are an incredible combination to
hear that you were going what does the
transition like from going from the film
like what we do in the shadows which is
an intimate movie that you worked on for
a long time - did you know mega tentpole
with a character that everyone already
knows yeah beta food for us that onset
and you know just just what Christmas
borders of what he was up to I was also
bored of what he was up to and when he
reached down here Eve I just saw a
friend of Neath at a
you know and that's just who I am is my
nature
ha ha ha you know if you need help if
you need me Louie from the dark tips on
their voyage and then we may have to
take one attempt only viewable so that's
really all so sorry Dominator the
typical sentiment was got moving from a
tiny little to the giant one after like
a lot of pressure obviously in the day
what he was inside that rectangle is
over my apartment smoke even with the
crew yes we're in your mind America and
most of these people is not
okay so very serious respect with all
people of Tom Hiddleston crease a couple
years ago you came out here in full
costume there was a full production and
one of the most memorable and incredible
moments of comic-con and you have fun
right how could you not have fun with
that unique experience which I will be
eternally grateful for for late
so what what has Loki been up to with
this one well it's been four years and
if you saw Thor the dark world you will
know that at the end of that film Loki
is on the throne of Asgard pretending to
be Odin so called concern and things a
little different in as god Loki he is
directed most of his energy into
narcissistic self flora fication sees
not so much time on good governance but
Ragnarok is coming and located
allegiances are always been slightly
unpredictable and and he's still the god
of mischief and we're what his part is
in all of that you'll just have to wait
and see alright I feel like they will I
feel like they're going to see it I feel
like this crowd is probably to see this
movie we're not thinking I feel like
they're on board with it
like they're on board of it mark almost
it I'm gonna stand on it here in the pan
I'm gonna fit you beat me up
maybe keep him out to see if the movie I
wanna see the movie what should we talk
about the evolution of the Hulk a little
bit but is it the evolution of the Hulk
the Hulk is a movie that you your
character ISM well it's a little
different Hulk than we see he Hulk's
refuses to turn back into banners and
he's actually enjoying his time on the
car because he is a gladiator champion
of the world of the car which means he
kicks a lot of a because it says right
here please be aware that many members
of your audience may be under the age of
18
it is very nice of you to honor that
literally nobody [ __ ] with other people
he kicks a lot of a that and and and
he's enjoying his life for once and
he'll be damned if he's going to go back
to ban again look a harsh language I
don't know why you had me there
damn the swearword I don't know probably
now I just think kids you can't offend
them at all anymore because the Internet
it was going to matter anymore so is he
sort of he is kind of a perma hook at
this point he's a little pearl home yeah
and he started to be able because it's
been the Hulk for two years now he he
has a vocabulary of a two-year-old so we
have a speaking hole can I say that well
too late we may or may not have a
speaking hole assistance or three where
everyone may or may not shine fair
enough I read it up Oh Kate how did you
come into the marvel
[Applause]
I mean seriously yeah seriously there's
the theory happy accident I sort of live
in the same continent in psycho and the
flightless chief so he came I just saw a
friend in need you know someone is
reaching out the determined because
those words uh it's was a dating help
you know I'm grateful now that I mean
look it it's the universe that I've sort
of been highly dragged into the public
kids and yeah so yeah and afterwards I
got these guys and gal this with another
taken German yeah not worsen your the
collectors brother that look like why
the coat OD partner here you are the
collectors brother yes I'm the
collectors brother radicchio del Toro
we're very old we were we were elders
Realtors of the universe we came about
shortly after the Big Bang
don't the rest of us sorry
come on so whether you make that joke
but you say a instead of ass that's
really funny
my characters gather all we're the
oldest living creatures in the universe
yeah oldest living race they call it the
thing we review here after the Big Bang
Grandmaster and Jun and my brother
collector that's right
excellent and now I ruin and now I rule
on this planet to car and put together
games mostly I'm a game I love games and
and fighting fighting games and I put
together I'm going to give anything away
with the great great match between Hulk
and the new for your entertainment and
pleasure can you hear me down there
Tesla can you hear me here okay great
welcome welcome
so what can you say about boundaries or
anything you can say about boundaries
with you ah you know I was just another
friend of me you're welcome
now I'm thankful she's an elite warrior
of a star who's hanging out on the bar
for reasons that I can't really
elaborate on she has a relationship with
the Grandmaster it's not romantic
I mean maybe it used to be who knows he
the French were little pieces around
town and maybe an interesting one of
them hasn't faced godlike thing ah yeah
right
and so she brings him to Rome after
excellent Karl Urban who's the scourge
yeah are you out of your Vulcan mind
oh here we cross the streams man I love
it cross the streams they what did you
guys shoot the flu because they said you
shaved your head and you already have
like you're that masculine that your
hair immediately just yeah
mixie on vacation and I received a call
from Target who is Australia deep behind
enemy lines like I need help I'm so
literally that is why how come you do
not need and you know it's around about
so many Australian this is Jackson
Jackson
it's really [ __ ] my little part of
the Cape although again I have a glass
bottle full of nails yeah it is you know
I overruled and I almost didn't make it
to sit because when I came into
Australia that the customs officer asked
me if I had a criminal record and I said
all my other knives don't need one to
get
we're in for a talk my friend Eddie
stole that got four kids but thank God
thankful for that breaking news
Australia declares war on New Zealand
tomorrow at 11:00
yeah we're just kind of bridging the gap
between New Zealand in Australia come on
as you can see we're seeing a lot closer
to each other than shooting in two
cultures together the warring tribes are
spreading all over make me hot make a
baby make a baby made a movement if it
Rachel how to had happy history 14th
language you know if you talk about
ecology hello
can you talk about your history a little
bit working with Tiger Martinez for at
expunge of its own to be made yeah I
need to pull me in on tap for the egg
pinch and for the ride
yes right before my good luck charm off
popular and everything I did because
she's hidden she's awesome
you